herzlich willkommen auf sondern wir
machen wir ein ausflug der m&m wo es auf
vier etagen oder drei tagen einfach nur
einmal es gibt und mit wirklich fassen
bekommt mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay leute wir sind jetzt kurz vor der
mur da vorne sieht man schon allein von
autenrieth hier so lange für irgendwas
keine ahnung mehr auf jeden fall hätten
wir das jetzt aus ich hoffe dürfen war
für mich wäre einmal fragen und dann
werden wir im paradies sein
[Musik]
ich bin
dort werden wir drinnen angekommen dazu
relativ groß aus meine freundin war
vorher drin und liebig sein
jede menge monaten propagiert man
klassische london
mit einem blauen er wird einmal fahrer
was machen wir heute wohl gemerkt es
gibt hier den vier levels das heißt vier
etagen werden
und allein schon rüber
[Musik]
und welche farben von eminem wie es in
deutschland und m & m experten bestätigt
dass auch nichts kaufen gibt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay leute ich sehe hier schon dass hier
keine ahnung
dabei gibt ihr 20 millionen haben
permanent shopper heran
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alte angestellte erst mal eine fliege
[Musik]
ich schon jetzt über ein modell mit
meinem outfit ganz wichtig neues werk
das man sein apple zu einem landfahrzeug
[Applaus]
bewundert wie manche leute passen sich
im outfit angenehm und einfach nur fit
und rover viel wasser trinkt einmal fing
von einmal sagten die leute eine sache
wo ich mir ganz sicher bin dass die
normalerweise mit ihren spaten
routiniert durch jede straftat
mehr leute dafür zu werben
aber nicht um geld oder dann vorbei
gelaufen oder sogar frühzeitig
wir werden jetzt auch noch unseren namen
abwägen lassen weil möglicherweise das
kann man hier machen und herausfinden
welcher im griff
in die bereitwillig an welche modelle
die eine oder andere sache
also ich kann wirklich alles möglich
dort gibt es auch alle möglichen händen
heraus fortführen diesem artikel war
übernahm
anscheinend bin ich bis anfang mai dort
nach witten fanny gestellt werden okay
wir können wir in der runde mit unserem
homeboy blauem fahren
hier residierte bäcker kaufen die sind
aber aus plastik also nebeneinander
offiziell würde aber auf jeden fall zu
mir passt ich bin mir jetzt mal einen
raus der guten mir passen würde
dafür leute ist mein wetter beispiel
leute wir sind jetzt an dem standort für
eine hemmung präsentieren kann
dafür kommen sind die beste band aller
zeiten
doch weitergeht blackbetty möglich also
dass sie meinen leider gibt es dafür zu
viel geld der feuerwehrleute so
kompetent wie alle ich habe es gemacht
weil gewinnen übertrieben mit drinnen
fahrertür und wenn du mit robben
erwartet er noch ein paar sachen und
probieren die dann für euch natürlich
nur allein mit meiner familie meinen
verein drücken
[Musik]
im flughafen wie fronberg gleich zurück
blieben aber ich habe ja gesagt hat hier
die ganzen sachen noch austesten werde
und zwar als erstes 7 mm milchshake
gibt's bleibe ich in deutschland so
nicht zu kaufen geld wieder in die erben
ich weiß nicht ob wir jetzt auch noch
viele mac mit leute
lecker
nicht so gut wie echte erben ist aber
wirklich gut und gerne probiere ich noch
die geheimen farben der mm
ob sie komplett an als merkel
bekannterweise schmeckt jeder msm
also ich finde man muss schon sagen wie
sie mit dem geil auf einen dunkelblauen
china